ni la fe se le escapa a la Inteligencia
artificial la iglesia luterana alemana
una de las instituciones religiosas más
influyentes del país experimenta un
hecho sin precedentes los feligreses de
la iglesia de San Paula en la ciudad
bávara de fuerte asistieron a la primera
misa dirigida por Inteligencia
artificial a través de un Avatar sermón
oraciones y música en una celebración
que parece inspirada en una película de
ciencia ficción
me sorprendió gratamente lo bien que
funcionó pero una cosa que
definitivamente extrañé por supuesto fue
Simplemente la emotividad el servicio
religioso fue dirigido por predicadores
creados con Inteligencia artificial
creo que es muy probable que las
personas ahora realmente estén tratando
con Inteligencia artificial también en
el campo religioso creo que se está
integrando cada vez más en los servicios
de la iglesia en el ámbito religioso por
lo tanto este experimento es una
oportunidad importante para ponerse en
contacto con esta tecnología esta
celebración contó con una nutrida
asistencia de fieles motivados por su fe
y por la novedad tecnológica se calcula
que uno de cada cuatro alemanes es
protestante luterano
[Música]